حقيبه للطوارئ ما يوضع فيها ليس غذاء
صوفيا اليومي في المدرسه بل لاستخدامه ان
بقيت في ملجا مدرستها لوقت طويل في حال
تعرض مدينتها كييف لقصف
روسيا
يدربونهم للنزول الى الملجا ونرسل معهم
الطعام والماء في حال حدوث طارق
نعم عزيزتي ترسمون نحن قلقون نعم لكن
اطفالنا يتعلمون ويرسمون الامور بالنسبه
لهم طبيعيه ولا يشعرون بالضغوط تدرك
والدته صوفيا ان المخاطر المحدقه بطفلتها
كبيره لكن تطمينات السلطات واجراءات
السلامه في المدارس شجعتها على ارسال
ابنتها ومثلها امهات ثلاثه ملايين طالب
يدرسون حضوريا في عموم مدارس اوكرانيا
تتطلب الاجراءات وجود ملجا يتسع للطلاب
خلال فتره كل دوام والتدرب على التصرف في
حال الخطر كما يجري في هذه المدرسه
فصوفيا ورفاقها عليهم الاعتياد على التوجه
الى الملجا هنا قد يجلس الاطفال لساعات
بانتظار انتهاء انذارات الهجمات الجويه
التي تتعرض لها مدينتهم
الانذارات تصل عبر تطبيق الهواتف نعرف
حينها ان لدينا عشر دقائق للتصرف وعلى
معلماتنا جمع الاطفال ونذهب كلنا الى
الملجا نحن جاهزون الان نفسيا وعمليا في
مدرستنا لمواجهه اي خطر عودته هؤلاء
الطلاب ليست امرا عاديا بالنسبه للسلطات
مل المدارس المحتاجه ووضعت شروطا صارمه
تتعلق بالاجراءات المتبعه عند الطوارئ
جميع المعلمين والطلاب تلقوا تدريبات حول
كيفيه التصرف في حالات الطوارئ بالنسبه
لنا السلامه تاتي اولا والاهم من ذلك ان
الادارات العسكريه في المقاطعات هي التي
تتخذ القرار بشان شكل التعليم بناء على
تقييمها الامني سواء كان حضوريا او عبر
الانترنت او مدمجا وفي المدرسه يتبدد قلق
والده صوفيا مع انتهاء الدوام لكن عليها
وعلى زملائها الخروج من المدرسه فرادى
جماعات على مدى اكثر من ساعتين وفقا
لاجراءات السلامه قد تكون هذه الاجراءات
طمانينه الاهالي لكن ذلك لا يلغي مشاعر
القلق التي تنتاب الاسرى بشان سلامه
ابنائها ومستقبلهم التعليمي في ظل استمرار
حرب لا مؤشرات حتى الان على قرب نهايتها
من العاصمه الاوكرانيه ايه اب العقد
الجزيره